on va revenir sur le prime de koh lanta
les chéris couple prime de koh lanta
vendredi dans koh lanta quel beau geste
a fait teymuraz qu'est ce qu'il a fait
il a fabriqué un lit pour un autre
candidat
il a fait un don à l'association des ex
de benjamin castaldi
il a donné le la il a donné le chocolat
qu'il avait gagnée aux autres
d'aventuriers où il a laissé gagner un
de ses adversaires
qu'est-ce qui la traquent y regarder là
c'est le chocolat le chocolat qui a vu
gilles verdez t'as vu ça oui atterrira
il a fait une très belle action puisque
tu es où ira encore gagné l'épreuve de
confort et regardez ce qu'il a fait je
me permets de nice si vous voulez si je
peux vous faire une contre-proposition
typhon je laisse tout ça pour tout le
monde y aura d'autres propositions est
tellement belle que je l'acceptent
salles depuis le départ vous parlez de
theora comme d'une légende c'est une
ligne de plus à mettre dans le grand
livre de la légende à 8 de toit sont là
il fait pu confirmer ce qu'il est à dire
un véritable héros et pour moi ça
restera à jamais le meilleur aventurier
l'histoire de koh lanta des ouvrages
suis très triste qu il l'est pas prise
cette récompense je veux dire je ne
tapais sa part et c'est lui le héros
j'aurais bien aimé qu'il m'apprenne
celle là
avec claude avec chypre je suis triste
qu'il n'a pas prise parce que c'est
celui qui viennent qu'ils méritent on
l'a tout simplement ordinaire avait plus
le chocolat c'est orgasme cleanequity ou
irak a gagné sur le cas donné son
chocolat franchement s étaient beaux
seins à tadu vous dire ça c'était
exceptionnel
alors on va venir sur ce qui s'est passé
pendant le prime juge gilles verdez
voulait rayer voulait dire un truc
oui je n'ai pas du tout aimé ce geste
c'est quoi un repas de famille
le vainqueur d'une épreuve il garde son
cadeau sinon pour tout est partagé ya
plus de vainqueurs ou perdants ou est là
pour les voir là dedans il ya mois à
ghassira la luna s'il vous plaît il ya
cyril hanouna qui sur twitter qui te dis
va acheter des marques jusqu'à 70 balais
nous fait pas si oui je retiens michel
bréard
vous êtes très agréable à écouter mais
vous êtes des enfants tout est stratégie
dans koh lanta évidemment ils se sont en
danger à mon insu ans en quête de
confort il s'assure un peu de
pragmatisme la part des autres candidats
ils m'ont l'adorent théorie raon
l'adorent mais vérifiez allergiques
d'allergie toshack a dangereux vide
alors qu'il ya aussi il ya eu aussi une
épreuve d'immunité il s'agit de
l'épreuve de l'étoile alors l'épreuve de
l'étoile qu'est-ce que c'est l'objectif
c'est de rester le plus longtemps
possible
immobile en se maintenant avec les pieds
et les mains sur des plans c'est à dire
c'est une tannée mon frère je veux dire
les toits la cérémonie finie l'attendait
toile comme ça ferait ratures est en
étoile pendant huit ans la particularité
de cette épreuve et qu'il n'y avait pas
un mais deux aventuriers qui ont
finalement pu remporter l'immunité
c'est une des premières fois que ça
arrive regardez c'était dans koh lanta
c'était vendredi en train de disputer
l'épreuve d'immunité
mais je vous propose à toutes et à tous
une alternative écoutez moi bien
une autre possibilité d'être intouchable
ce soir au conseil l'objectif à mon top
départ est uniquement à mon top départ
ce sera de quitter l'étoile de passer
sous les de rondins et de venir taper
sur le poteau qui vous fait face est
interdite
di grappa des glaces
jessica c'est bon jessica est
intouchable ce soir au conseil saluent
la famille la patrie c'est vrai qu'il
est bien au pied ont glissé d'attaqué
sam nickel chrome
j'avais dans mon oreille
j'avais connu nawel pour l'emporter
1h04 bravo ils sont restés une heure et
quatre minutes à faire les toiles un
mois qu'on peut tenir et moi ce réseau
et moi je peux moi ce que je peux faire
à ce prix là je peux faire le bon leader
et 4 minutes
ils veulent du pilote favori jean michel
maire c'est une épreuve que j'aurais été
un matin parce qu'avec le monde oignons
j'aurais bien l'accroché mois sortait
l'autorité de gens là là mais quel jour
d'heure alors les chéris sachez que
vendredi les stratégies c'est de retour
et certains aventuriers se sont mis en
tête de trouver un collier d'immunité
alors t'es où ira a réussi à en trouver
un et c'est pas le cas de sam
mais sam a tenté un coup de poker
regarder koh lanta ça a cartonné samedi
soir garde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
ça
[Musique]
aller plus loin a changé
alors voilà et donc sam a été éliminé
lors du conseil
alors koh-lanta ça cartonne est ce que
vous êtes choqués du départ de sam pour
se connaître
samse l'aventurier c'était le meilleur
aventurier de cette saison - on va pas
se mentir gilles verdez très choqué très
choqué il est jeune il est dynamique il
s'est entraîné
il a chuté sur une épreuve qu'il aurait
dû gagner d'ailleurs il s'en voulait je
trouve ça inadmissible qu'on vire le
meilleur parce qu'il fait je ne supporte
pas ça c'est le bal bars avec c'est ce
que j'ai fait moi c'est ce que je vais
faire avec jean michel maire je pense à
des prochaines oui sofico non mais ça a
toujours été comme ça si l'allemand en
fait ça a toujours été comme ça que j'en
passe c'est à dire que quand on est très
fort on se fait éliminer comme tu dit
gilles c'est exactement ça c'est chaud
c'est l'apologie de la médiocrité par
excellent bravo bien sûr on aura les
verseaux dans un instant des taux fixes
bien sûr les versions bien sûr si vous
n'aimez pas la mayonnaise manger de la
moutarde